I'm about to enter the West Bank and as
you can see from this sign Israelis are
not allowed to enter this is a
Palestinians owned by Israeli crew
that's been with me for a few days must
remain behind and I'm gonna switch over
to an all palestinian crew so it's like
this court-ordered custody fight where
i'm leaving one divorce parent to go
stay with another divorced parent and
both parents don't really like me i want
to buy for you you know why why because
you are in Bethlehem's oh that's so nice
of you thank you that's tonight he just
gave this to me that's very nice you're
welcome I'll be back in five minutes to
take more for free hot dip what is your
what is your name my name is Sammy Sammy
Sammy what are you from where were you
from you live yes damn I bet you have
yes I did here I live here I'm born in
and married here also Wow yes what do
you have here I have some coffee and I
have also very delicious see this coffee
looks very very strong very strong gusts
nah you are like God king of the jungle
no meek and mild sugar oh my god very
strong no wonder you are so huh yes yes
yes did you seem a little crazy
this is for you but put this right in
here okay go on Betty fun
I am very typing you were very nice I
love the color I kiss you too okay well
you're very heavy we're not the lips
right well you want to come
[Applause]
my heart is like my face dancing music
for dancing he's good so much so good
this man show me I'll be how to dance
how do I dance okay got it
this is it did you see you like this
[Music]
he's got where'd he go stop I guess I
win
but hover is good my mother have a good
shoe a smock this is me bouncing me
massive person asked me corner corner :
hello sir I want to buy something I have
a with you here like this is hubbly
bubbly how much how much for this we're
like this 700 chicken said it had a
check us is [ __ ] just down the
street
this looks just like this you know Mike
this is digger issue yeah yeah nice 5450
circles is [ __ ] I'll give you 500
shekels give you 390 shekels ok
oh yes
[Applause]
[Music]
haha I've just bought this but I don't
have what goes in what goes in here what
is this you know what I'm gonna do
watermelon and I like that this is like
watching my dad do the Christmas lights
seventies except you're not swearing
kicking things okay yeah alright yeah
it's just yeah okay what this gentleman
is telling me is that this hooker is no
good it's decorative it doesn't work
it's not meant to work if this is bad
the whole thing no good my fault right I
bought a decorative hookah learn from my
mistake next time you're in the West
Bank look out for this guy I like this
guy but he doesn't make it clear that
he's selling you a decorative hooker and
not a functioning hooker
[Applause]
of course not the good
that is some fine watermelon and made us
money okay
he's high on watermelon
you